this could be the future of football no
pads no helmets no tackling and lots of
selfies
welcome to professional flag football
seriously the most extreme reaction I
got was you're out of your mind don't do
it this is Jeff Lewis a former Wall
Street guy and the founder of the
American flag football league it's a new
tech tout version of pigskin and when
Lewis first brought up the AFF L not
everyone was into it what the people who
said I was crazy I shouldn't do it did
was they made comments that forced me to
research what was driving their
negativity so Lewis and his team scoured
social media comments during NFL games
and they found something sort of
surprising and what we saw is what do
people talk about when they're watching
football games and what they talk about
is pass run touchdown interception
they don't say sack hit block tackle the
reason that people are gonna want to pay
attention to this is they're gonna see
the athleticism of these guys in a way
they never did when they were wearing
gear the flag football he imagines is
not that different from the flag
football you've probably played before
with your friends that's part of the
point but there is at least one key
difference and that's the tech first off
the players wear electronic flags when
they're pulled a signal gets sent up
here to this computer then the precise
location gets relayed back to the refs
so there's no confusion about where the
play ended the goal is to make a product
that's more exciting higher scoring and
just faster well the first AFL
tournament isn't scheduled until 2018
the inaugural game recently took place
at Avaya Stadium in San Jose California
it didn't have a ton of fans but that's
okay the books that did show were
passionate I don't care that's flag
football I wouldn't watch that lettis
ism you know good players it takes it
back to when we were kids we used to
play
you know and I love that and at the end
of the day like all pro sports these
games were really just TV shows and
that's what lewis approaches it the AFF
L collaborated with company called SMT
which invented things like the virtual
first down line and that little score
box that's now on every sports broadcast
everywhere they worked for months to
make watching these games feel almost
like playing Madden we are actually
doing the virtual lines and all the
virtual graphics that we're providing
from that Skycam SM T's latest tech is
an elaborate player tracking system
called oasis-c those patches on every
players shoulder they're pinging
wideband wireless signals all over the
stadium which can map their location in
real time we can track like how far our
players running the top speed distance
all that type of stuff Oasis can also
track players heart rates watch for head
injuries and do much more to help keep
players safe ultimately that's what this
platform is for because even though the
NFL is a juggernaut the backlash against
what football does to player's bodies is
real lots of parents won't even let
their kids play tackle football anymore
it may not make for great marketing but
a safer version of football could set
the a FFL apart you know what is great
marketing though famous athletes for the
first game louis recruited some big-name
former footballers guys like mike vick
and Terrell Owens and Chad Ochocinco and
he told them to take selfies go live and
tweet to their heart's content we got a
lot of guys that supported us and what
we're trying to do carry roles and CEO
Chad and you know it's exciting man it
is some different than I enjoyed it
let's be realistic here
the AFL and its aging superstars are not
going to take down the NFL there's a
long history of league trying to disrupt
the biggest sport in America and they
always lose but don't be surprised if
the NFL football you see in a few years
looks a little more like this a faster
pace
fix the selfies to focus on player
tracking biometric data and player
safety it all makes for exciting
football and great Instagram posts